what I want to do in this video see if
we can evaluate the definite integral
from negative 3 to 3 of the square root
of 9 minus x squared DX
and I encourage you to pause this video
and try it on your own and I'll give you
a hint
you can do this purely by looking at the
graph of this function alright so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it so let's
just think about I just told you that
you could do this using the graph of the
function so let's graph this function so
let's let's get a let's get a y-axis
here so this is my y axis this is my x
axis x axis and you might be saying oh
well what is what is the graph of this
thing it might not jump out at you it's
been a little while it's as a hint since
you've done conic sections maybe in your
algebra class but let's just remind
ourselves so if this this function so if
we said Y is equal to some function of X
which we see is the square root of 9
minus x squared then we could say well
that means that Y squared must be equal
to this thing squared which is 9 minus x
squared and then we could say Y squared
plus x squared is equal to 9 and you
might recognize this as a circle circle
centered at origin circle centered at
origin with radius radius equal to 3 the
square root of 9 so radius is equal to 3
centered at the origin now the graph of
this is not going to be a circle this is
a function this is a function so this is
it would be a circle and it would not be
a function anymore if you said the
positive and negative square roots of
year so when we took the square root we
kind of got that or when we took the
squares of both sides we got the the
bottom back I guess you could say but up
here we're only talking about the
principal root so when you're talking
about the principal root you're really
talking about the top this is the top of
a sort of a circle centered at the
origin with radius 3 so this is top of
circle because it's the positive square
root so let's draw that it's gonna
radius of three so centered at the
origin so this is going to be negative
three this is going to be three this is
going to be three right over here so
this graph this function is going to
look like this it is going to look like
this and it's actually only defined
between negative 3 & 3 if you the
absolute value of X is greater than 3
then you're gonna get a negative value
in here and then you can't take the the
principal root if we're defining it over
over real if we're if we're defining it
over positive or non-negative values I
should say so this is the graph so what
is the definite integral from negative 3
to 3 well it's just the area under the
curve and above the x-axis is the stuff
that I am shading in and green well
what's that well you don't need calculus
to figure that out you can do this with
just traditional geometry the area of
the entire the area of the entire circle
if there were an entire circle will just
be PI R squared so it would be pi times
3 squared which is equal to 9 pi now
this is only half of the entire circle
so we're going to divide that by 2 so
the area is 9 PI over 2 so this thing is
9 PI over 2